okay so we're here from Critics
Association Awards how you feeling about
tonight this is always a fun night yeah
it's always a fun night you know who
will win the vast majority of films
right Nance which i think is interesting
because Toronto Film Critics they
decided will tell everyone what's going
to happen it's like the spoiler alert
Awards they tell ya like who's nominated
tell you who won except of course for
the big award that Roger sponsors yeah
this is $100,000 death by Swedish film
is best Canadian film which is
phenomenal and and you can't help but
love that because you know filmmakers it
takes forever to make a film and it's
it's hard ol slog and $100,000 is a
game-changer yeah for most artists in
Canada so it's great yeah so what are
you presenting tonight I presented the
emerging critic Awards okay how do you
feel about critics well this is it as an
individual who's had a few bad reviews
us in his life never I don't believe oh
I might be reading some tonight III
never thought that I would be asked to
celebrate critics right although I do
celebrate okay know when I'm asked to do
something I celebrate but it's
interesting I think everyone whether an
actor playwright or a writer and don't
make her you know anyone we all have a
very interesting relationship with
critics right yeah yeah have you ever
acted the gut have I ever acted up did
you just ask like being like movies and
I don't know you like sketching it have
you ever I mean in a few little movies
yeah yeah but you've never got like the
huge like in terms of going in that
direction and I know no I always felt I
used to get parts and small parts and
movies and then when I kind of became
Rick Mercer because I had a TV show you
know I'd say that Dom Michela or someone
why don't you put me in the movie it's
like we're not putting you in there
because you're little distracted yeah
you're not the geography teacher so at
least that's what they told me they'd
seen your password yeah I don't know
stick with what you know yeah
yeah but do you miss doing the Rick
Mercer report like it's been about two
years now right yeah not even but yeah
I'm there's lots that I miss about
having a TV show but I I'm still glad
that we wrapped it up the way we wrapped
it up and I've done a lot of stuff you
know I went on a big cross-country
stand-up comedy tour which was something
I've wanted to do for 16 years and I
never got a chance to do it and that I
went into the comedy clubs and did
Amateur Night and open mic nights and
and learned how to be a stand-up god
yeah and and I ended up going across the
country doing 40 minutes a night with
all these great comics and that was a
that was a great learning curve for me
and it scared the hell out of me and I
like that is it freeing in a way like to
not have that like TV schedule it's like
what I want to do it's it's different
for sure I never minded the schedule no
I didn't stop because I mean it was
never-ending and it was relentless but I
never minded that I didn't mind the
travel I didn't I didn't mind anybody in
fact I loved at all and so you know
there's I miss it but it's just
different yeah like do you miss having a
platform to put your opinions out there
not too much no she's not going on to
talk about all there's a lot going on
but of course if I wants it to do that
right now I could there's all sorts of
ways to do it
and there's lots of places I could go do
it but I'm taking a break from that yeah
I mean I don't stop ranting I'm
constantly you know call the police but
because I'm curious your thoughts of a
Carrie and Megan with this whole
stepping down for the Royals yeah I
don't really have thoughts about every
circles like I'm sure you talked with
the royal family of over the years right
yeah a little bit no I know I don't know
where of them I think it's something you
know I think hey that's what they want
to do I don't really understand what it
means I do I'm happy for them I just
want people to be happy okay
that's good no yeah he's a 35 year old
man for God says and it was like he
didn't he
angered his grandmother was a 35 year
old man he's gonna move out of the house
true yeah
move over to Canada come here yeah is
that real that he's moving to Canada
there's no time in North America right
yeah we'll see we'll see now so Canada's
very nice I'm sure would be very
welcoming oh it's true we'd love to have
and I'm sure it would be very difficult
being a royal in Canada no in London
yes oh yeah they're awful yeah now in
terms of tonight like being in a room
but I don't know about that you will
hate this about vodka it's like when
people say something about a Kardashian
yeah and I feel like they're talking
about a planet I've never heard I
couldn't pick her out of a out of a
lineup can you name any of them no Kim
doesn't in this game of course yeah I
know that cunning by osmosis Courtney
how many are there uh there's four card
I can't believe I'm gonna give a lesson
on this there's Kim Kourtney Khloe and
Rob or Kardashians
then there's Kylie and Kendall who are
though one direction okay so we're done
with her Megan yes okay I'm happy for
them god bless them okay yeah good oh
okay what are we talking about this I
was gonna ask for tonight oh yes so
being in a room yeah with a bunch of
people the industry like what does that
feel like this is always a fun show yeah
it's it's not a televised show it's
always just a good time and people are
pretty relaxed and as I said I'm giving
away in emerging critics awards that'll
be battles dang critics oh yeah but they
deserve Awards too but that's all we do
in show business is get rewards yeah I
mean I never done I mean the critics
don't get awards but you know did you
see Ricky Gervais on the Golden Globes
yeah would you think I thought some of
it was really funny
yeah yeah I liked you surprised he went
that far in terms like no I knew we
would yeah I think everyone do he did
what like I think he he had said it's
set it up that if he didn't do that he
would have been vilified for not - right
yeah